monsieur le Président
je lui laisserai le président Montaugé
le fait d'excuser madame prima qui qui
n'a pu nous rejoindre Mesdames et
Messieurs mes chers collègues
découplage du prix du gaz et de
l'électricité plafonnement du prix du
gaz extension du mécanisme ibérique
réforme du marché européen de
l'électricité l'Union européenne est
divisée sur les moyens à mettre en œuvre
pour parvenir à limiter la hausse des
prix de l'électricité en Europe
une hausse qui a débuté en 2021 avec la
reprise économique qui a suivi la
pandémie et qui s'est accentué en 2022
avec la guerre en Ukraine car le prix de
l'électricité grimpe avec ceux du gaz et
du Pétrole ainsi le prix de
l'électricité sur le marché de gros
européen avec déjà plus que doublé au
dernier trimestre 2021 et il s'est
maintenu en 2022 à un niveau très élevé
atteignant un pic inédit fin août à plus
de 1100 euros par mégawattheure
la France a été largement épargnée grâce
aux bouclier tarifaires même si la
première ministre a annoncé pour début
2023 une hausse des prix de
l'électricité de 15%. plusieurs États
membres dont la France appellent depuis
le début de la crise énergétique à une
réforme substantielle du marché pour
décorer les prix de l'électricité et des
énergies fossiles tandis que d'autres se
montrent très réservés à une évolution
des mécanismes des réunions du Conseil
européen et du Conseil de l'Union
européenne se succèdent pour tenter
d'apporter des réponses au moins
temporaires à cette situation mais les
positions restent figées certains états
considèrent que les propositions de la
Commission européenne manque d'empis
d'ambition et réclame des nouvelles
évolutions structurelles d'autres
mettent en avant les effets de bord des
mesures envisagées craignant en
particulier pour l'approvisionnement
énergétique de l'Europe
l'envoler des prix de l'électricité à
des niveaux parfois stratosphériques
comme en août a susciter des
interrogations et des inquiétudes sur
l'efficacité du marché européen de
l'électricité et le bien fondé de sa
conception actuelle à ce titre le
mécanisme de fixation des prix sur le
marché de gros largement considéré comme
responsable de la flambée des prix de
l'électricité est au centre des
critiques alors qu'en avril dernier un
rapport de l'Agence européenne de
coopération des régulateurs de l'énergie
plaidait pour conserver le mécanisme
actuel la Commission européenne a depuis
un fléchi sa position la présidente
Ursula vanderleyen a ainsi promis une
intervention d'urgence et une réforme
structurelle du marché de l'électricité
une proposition législative est attendue
pour début 2023 en attendant la
Commission européenne a proposé des
mesures d'urgence et de nouveaux
mécanismes de solidarité pour maîtriser
à très court terme la flambée des prix
de l'énergie dans l'Union
trois règlements ont déjà été adoptés
dans le cadre de la procédure accélérée
prévue par l'article 122 du traité
le TFUE le traité de fonctionnement de
l'Union européenne
la dernière proposition de la Commission
européenne mise sur table lors de la
réunion des ministres de l'énergie le 24
novembre dernier un plafonnement des
prix du gaz sur la bourse néerlandaise
TTF à déçu les états partisans d'un
mécanisme de plafonnement et d'un
découplage des prix du gaz et de
l'électricité mais il a fortement
inquiété ce qui s'oppose à toute mesure
de cette nature reflétant l'antagonisme
des positions françaises et allemandes
je laisse maintenant la parole à Franck
Montauger merci monsieur le Président
chers
collègues
je salue nos invités je les remercie
d'avoir accepté de participer à cette
table ronde et de nous faire partager
leur expertise sur la sur la situation
problématique que nous vivons
et puis vous vous présenterez je pense
qu'en voilà après nos interventions
préliminaires monsieur le mes chers
collègues nous nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui pour cette table ronde sur
le thème donc de la réforme du marché
européen de l'électricité c'est la
quatrième fois que nous échangeons
ensemble sur l'énergie après une
première table ronde sur la crise
énergétique européenne mais aussi nos
travaux au long cours sur la taxonomie
verte européenne et le paquet ajustement
à l'objectif 55 je remercie le président
rappin de ces échanges fructueux notre
commission des affaires économiques très
engagées en faveur de la réforme du
marché européenne l'électricité nous
avons en effet demandé une révision du
principe du coup marginal qui lit
aujourd'hui sur le marché de gros de
l'électricité le prix de l'électricité à
celui du gaz ce point a figurer dans les
cinq mesures pour sortir la dépendance
au gaz russe que nous avons proposé le
28 février dernier quelques jours après
le lancement de l'invasion russe en
Ukraine mais aussi dans nos rapports
d'informations de mars dernier sur le
volet énergie du paquet à justement et
sur le nucléaire et l'hydrogène en
juillet dernier quel est votre analyse
de la crise énergétique actuelle selon
vous est-elle due à des facteurs
conjoncturels ou structurels un
consensus énergétique en Europe pour
découpler le prix du gaz de celui de
l'électricité comme le demande de la
France ou à minima pour plafonner le
prix du gaz comme l’homme obtenu le
Portugal et l'Espagne notre commission
est aussi très impliquée dans la mise en
oeuvre du plan ripower
U qui doit permettre à l'Union
européenne de sortir de sa dépendance
aux hydrocarbures russes d'ici 2030 bien
consciente de la nécessité de la
difficulté de cet exercice notre
commission a fait adopter une résolution
une résolution forte sur ce sujet
appuyez par le parlementaires des 27
États membres européens le 14 mars
dernier dans le cadre de la conférence
inter parlementaire de la présidence
française de l'Union européenne depuis
lors le règlement du 6 octobre 2022 qui
autorise une intervention d'urgence pour
atténuer les effets des prix élevés a
été adopté est-il messieurs à la hauteur
des enjeux car il nous semble que son
volet électricité est plus étoffé et que
celui relatif au gaz et que pensez-vous
des mesures visant à réduire la
consommation plafonner les recettes ou
appliquer les tarifs réglementés au PME
par exemple de nombreux pays européens
sont-ils saisis est-ce pour vous une
réponse adaptée et pérenne notre
commission est aussi très investie dans
la mise en oeuvre du paquet ajustement
55 qui doit permettre à l'Union
européenne de réduire de 55%, ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
2030 parce que la décarbonation de notre
économie nécessite de doubler la
production d'électricité notre
commission a fait adopter une résolution
complète à cette fin en commun avec la
commission des affaires européennes et
celle du développement durable l'une des
conclusions et la nécessité de garantir
une neutralité technologique entre les
différentes énergies décarbonées
nucléaires comme renouvelables il nous
semble en effet que des projets de
directive sur la taxation de l'énergie
et les énergies renouvelables mais aussi
les projets de règlement sur le paquet
gazier les carburants aériens et les
carburants maritimes défavorisent
l'énergie nucléaire par rapport aux
énergies renouvelables quel est votre
point de vue ne doit-on pas faire
davantage pour cette source d'énergie
des carbonée je vous remercie des
éléments que vous pourrez apporter sur
ces sur ces sujets majeurs et je forme
le vœu que la réforme du marché européen
de l'électricité soit l'occasion pour
l'Union européenne de sortir de sa
dépendance aux énergies fossiles et de
valoriser toutes les formes d'énergie
décarbonée nucléaires comme renouvelable
voilà je vais vous nous allons vous
passer la parole bien entendu Daniel
grimier c'est ça doit s'exprimer
juste un point que j'ai omis
quel manexus madame sauf le prima
présidente de la commission économique
n'a pas pu être parmi nous ce matin pour
des raisons personnelles et elle m'a
demandé donc de la de la supplier ce que
je fais avec plaisir mais je la salue et
je sais qu'elle s'excuse auprès de nous
tous voilà merci Franck peut-être Daniel
après les intervenants je pense
qui a la double casquette commission des
affaires européennes et commission des
Affaires éco aussi
je laisse d'abord la parole à Monsieur
Jean-Michel glachon qui est président de
l'Association internationale de de
l'énergie après oui il parlera après les
selon vous quelles sont les limites du
fonctionnement actuel du marché européen
de l'électricité mais question sont bien
sûr en lien avec celle de Frank
Montauger quel bilan tirez-vous de
l'ouverture de la concurrence du secteur
de l'électricité et nous serions très
intéressés si vous pouviez introduire
votre propos par une présentation de
l'organisation du marché et de
l'évolution des prix de l'électricité en
Europe globalement on se donne à peu
près 10 minutes par intervenant afin
aussi de laisser la parole au collègues
et les éventuels questions qu'ils
pourraient vous poser monsieur glachon
c'est à vous
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
vice-président mesdames messieurs je
suis très honoré par la demande que vous
m'avez faite de venir vous présenter ici
en salle Médicis un tour d'horizon des
marchés européens vu de la ville des
Médicis Florence je suis professeur des
universités délégués un institut
européen de Florence et j'ai été élu par
mes pères présidents de l'Association
Internationale fonction que je prends le
16 décembre à philadelphieuse États-Unis
je procéderai en trois étapes
premièrement l'organisation le
fonctionnement des marchés électriques
où j'opposerai un modèle léger le modèle
européen à un modèle lourd le modèle
britannique ou américain deuxièmement je
regarderai quelques conséquences
positives de l'ouverture européenne et
je marquerai de fortes limites de ce
modèle troisièmement
je regarderai deux chocs de prix
différents celui de 202122 et celui de
20224 qui appelle selon moi des
politiques différentes je pars dans le
premièrement
l'organisation et le fonctionnement
notre modèle européen est un modèle
léger il s'oppose au modèle lourd et
organisé anglo-saxons le pull
britannique ou le pool de Pennsylvanie
nous jersey Maryland
ce modèle lourd organisé réalise un
dispatch de toutes les unités de
production unité par unité pour chaque
demi-heure personne ne peut produire
sans l'ordre du dispatch central
pennsylvénie Maryland ajoute un calcul
nodal des prix chaque noeud du réseau à
son prix il y a jusqu'à plusieurs
centaines de nœuds et le prix notre
modèle léger européen n'a aucun
disparaissent central chaque offreur
gère lui-même son portefeuille d'unité
nos prix sont zono une zone peut même
être un pays de la taille de la France
ce modèle européen n'a jamais été dicté
par la commission c'est un résultat
empirique national ces résultats
nationaux ont été réutilisés par les
transporteurs français belges
néerlandais
pour coupler tous nos marchés nationaux
en un seul marché européen comment par
un calcul de capacité garantie de
transport transfrontaliers c'est le
couplage des marchés nationaux qui est
le cœur des échanges européens il
utilise les réseaux nationaux comme ils
sont
ce cœur a été enrichi d'un grand nombre
de codes européens de réseau
conçu par l'Association européenne des
transporteurs Enzo i en dialogue avec
l'Agence européenne de coopération des
régulateurs nationaux a fait vous voyez
que tout ce travail est pragmatique et
empirique il a été réalisé sur plus de
10 ans et continue encore aujourd'hui
bonne conséquence ce modèle européen est
uniquement ni les États-Unis ni le
Canada ni l'Australie n'y sont pas venus
certes c'est un modèle léger mais il est
soutenu par le couplage de tous nos
marchés nationaux et par des codes
communs de réseau il ouvre donc chaque
système électrique national à tous les
autres et permet d'optimiser le
fonctionnement de tout le parc européen
des milliers d'unités et même des
centaines de milliers avec le
renouvelable c'est incroyablement
efficace et ça marche 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 à l'échelle européenne même
la Chine s'y intéresse dans sa réflexion
nationale sur le couplage des marchés
régionaux chinois
le centre de recherche de steak great
China soutient la traduction chinoise de
mon manuel de 650 balles blue et un
résumé gratuit de 75 pages
si vous voulez apprendre le chinois
c'est l'occasion ou jamais
quelques conséquences je continue ce
modèle européen ouvert a permis un
succès industriel mondial dans les
éoliennes les deux premières entreprises
mondiales en fabrication d'éoliennes
sont européennes la Danoise vestaf est
numéro un mondial général et numéro 1
aux États-Unis la Germano espagnol
Siemens Gamesa est numéro un mondial en
éolien maritime le Danemark prépare
aussi des plateformes maritimes géantes
des hubs de 10 GW à 20 GW l'objectif
européen général en maritime et de 60
gigawatts en 2030 c'est la part de tout
le parc c'est la taille de tout le parc
nucléaire français et 300 GW 340
gigawatts en 2050 c'est deux fois et
demi la puissance installée en France
plus l'apparition de géants de
l'électricité renouvelable hainel et
d'épée hiverdrolin mais aussi venant du
gaz et du Pétrole total énergie ou BP
question réelle notre modèle européen
ouvert est-il anti-nucléaire il est tout
à fait vrai que les centrales au gaz
n'avaient pas de risque de prix de
marché puisqu'elle le forme le nucléaire
oui regardons le câble britannique
néanmoins
construit deux EPs et ça ils jouent elle
va rajouter deux EPR de plus comment
pragmatique le gouvernement britannique
garantit par des contrats de long terme
le prix de vente de nucléaire jusqu'à
100 euros le mégorateurs c'est plus que
deux fois la reine en France ce sont des
contrats pour différence approuvés par
les commissions européennes quand les
renouvelables sont venus baisser les
revenus des centrales au gaz on a étendu
ce pragmatisme les centrales au gaz
peuvent toucher des revenus de capacité
sur le marché des capacités en plus du
prix de vente de l'énergie ceci
également été approuvé par la commission
européenne
mais soyons francs ce modèle européen
2000 2010 est dépassé et il est dépassé
trois fois il nous faut un autre modèle
premièrement les investissements
productifs ne sont plus basés sur les
prix de marché de gros il faut en
prendre actes et organiser toutes les
entrées en investissement par des
contrats de long terme ces fameux
contrats pour différence ou bien des
contrats d'approvisionnement bilatéraux
en anglais PPA
tout en disant une planification souple
des évolutions technologiques par
exemple il faut pousser le maritime
flottant ou la France comme le Portugal
aurait un véritable avantage cette
réorganisation des schémas
d'investissement fourniraient aussi une
base solide à la stabilité à long terme
des prix de gros la Commission de
régulation française dit que les
renouvelables français reverseraient aux
autorités publiques en 20223 une
trentaine de milliards d'euros
deuxièmement il faut favoriser plus
d'investissements en résilience du
système électrique en donnant à ces
fameux marchés de capacité la mission
d'accroître la flexibilité de la demande
comme une ressource en résilience le
Sénat pourrait par exemple s'intéresser
aux champions national en France
Schneider Electric
troisièmement il faut aussi renforcer la
stabilité des prix de gros en favorisant
des marchés de couverture par exemple en
les alimentant par des obligations
réglementaires de couverture des
fournisseurs on pourrait même à
l'échelle européenne créer un marché de
couverture des fournitures de base qui
seraient l'équivalent de notre
définition française des services
publics garantie
1 + 2 + 3 un nouveau modèle européen
qu'on pourrait appeler un modèle
européen hybride avec plusieurs types de
marché et des politiques publiques
fortes
les crises de choc le premier choc était
2001 février 2022 était 2021 pardon une
sortie du covid désordonnée
inflationniste il était donc
parfaitement légitime de prolonger le
quoi qu'il en coûte pour ne pas bloquer
la reprise économique en ciblant les
ménages beaucoup de manières de le faire
en Espagne sur les prix de gros c'est
bizarre de toucher au prix de gros pour
changer les prix de l'État mais c'est
typique de l'Espagne en France touché au
prix de l'État également fait un
Grande-Bretagne mais vous avez vu avec
des faillites de fournisseurs être
direct au ménage sans toucher au prix
formule allemande étalement pluriannuel
des factures formules danoises mais
notre bouclier tarifaire était au cœur
des réponses à ce problème et les
réponses nationales étaient ici
parfaitement légitime et appropriée on
n'avait pas besoin d'une réponse
européenne le nouveau choc à mes yeux et
le choc politique russe à partir de mars
2022 la menace d'une coupure ou d'une
pénurie de gaz le sujet n'est plus le
prix mais les volumes il faut baisser
les volumes consommés et trouver du GNL
ou du gazoduc un peu partout mais il n'y
aurait pas de desserrement net de l’œuf
avant 2025 ou 206 il faut donc serrer la
vis au consommation il n'y a pas
d'échappatoire le bouclier tarifaire
national n'est plus au cœur des remèdes
c'est devenu un couple symptômes qui est
bon une aspirine pendant la fièvre mais
ne ce n'est pas un remède qui agit sur
les causes quand la demande européenne
semble incontrôlée les marchés peuvent
bondir vers le prix de la défaillance
jusqu'à 10000 euros le mégawattheure ce
qui devient un problème européen
collectif et non plus national il y a
donc utilité à une surveillance
européenne des consommations et à des
achats européens groupés mais vous
constaterez comme moi que ceci ne nous
donne pas de réponse claire à la perte
de compétit de nos gros exportateurs ou
de zone industrielle électro-intensifs
enfin un peu l'anglais sur les efforts
d'abstinence en turquoise les réductions
de consommation de gaz par les ménages
ou les professionnels en bleu outre-mer
le mouvement de la consommation de gaz
pour production d'électricité de modèles
s'opposent l'Allemagne germanique vous
voyez que l'Allemagne a réduit de 100 tt
sa consommation de gaz le modèle
espagnol Spain où on a réduit un peu pas
beaucoup la consommation des ménages et
des professionnels et augmenter beaucoup
vraiment beaucoup près de 25 terwetteurs
la consommation de gaz pour produire de
l'électricité choisissez votre modèle je
ne dirai rien de la France car dans la
salle Médicis la France ce n'est pas moi
c'est le Sénat merci
pour pas regarder le contact etc même
sur Twitter
on a bien noté
l'approche de la langue chinoise dans
votre dans votre synthèse
je vais donner la parole maintenant à
Monsieur Laurent Ménard qui est
directeur des affaires économiques et
financières de la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie vous êtes
accompagné par Monsieur Antoine de
reddre chef économiste à la cour à la
creux
vous êtes expert du fonctionnement du
marché de l'électricité en tant que
régulateur français finalement quel est
votre analyse par rapport même aux
propos très intéressants qui viennent de
nous être fournis
oui par rapport à ce que j'avais prévu
de dire j'ai un petit peu modifié compte
tenu de ce qui vient d'être dit donc
bonjour
bonjour monsieur le Président bonjour
monsieur le vice-président comme vous
l'avez dit je suis le directeur des
affaires économiques et financières de
la Creuse depuis un peu plus de 3 ans
maintenant donc j'ai eu le bonheur d'y
arriver au moment du début de la crise
énergétique
je voudrais souligner dans par rapport à
ce que vient nous dire monsieur glachon
à quel point le modèle de marché tel
qu'il a été mis en place en Europe
est un modèle pragmatique
assez éloigné des modèles peut-être plus
purs entre guillemets qui ont été mis en
place aux États-Unis où au Royaume-Uni
et j'avais prévu de vous présenter une
slide qui qui dit beaucoup si on prend
le marché français de l'électricité des
prix de gros français d'abord comme l'a
dit Monsieur glachon tout le pays est
une seule zone de prix donc il y a le
même prix de gros sur les marchés gros
pour tout le territoire français ensuite
et ça a été également signé par Monsieur
clachant on n'est pas dans un marché où
chaque centrale
par
un organisme central en fait chaque
producteur vient proposer une offre de
prix chaque jour je reviendrai sur le
la frise temporelle des marchés mais
chaque producteur vient proposer chaque
jour un prix
qui intègre l'ensemble de son parc de
production donc chaque producteur à la
possibilité d'arbitrer les moyens de
production et le prix qu'il propose sur
le marché c'est très différent du
fonctionnement américain ou chaque
fonctionnement de certains marchés
américains vont être précis parce qu'il
y a plusieurs marchés aux États-Unis où
là c'est vraiment chaque centrale et le
coût marginal de chaque central qui est
pris en compte par un dispatcheur
central on n'est pas du tout dans cette
situation sur le marché européen et sur
le marché français
donc je voudrais un tout petit peu
insister
il y a eu un débat tout à fait légitime
sur le principe du
coût marginal en réalité dans son
fonctionnement concret
les prix proposés par les opérateurs
sont des prix qui reflètent leur
stratégie de vente sur le marché compte
tenu de l'ensemble de leur parc de
production
et pas compte tenu du coup marginal de
chaque
chacune de leurs centrales c'est un
point extrêmement important
ensuite sur le
l'emprise de ce marché
sur l'ensemble des ventes des
productions et des ventes d'électricité
là il faut il faut avoir vraiment en
tête que les transactions sur le marché
de l'électricité en France ça ne
représente qu'une petite partie
des soutirages qu'on peut avoir sur une
année là je vous ai mis sur le graphique
la part marcher
proprement dite de ces soutirages c'est
quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de 15%
alors ça veut pas dire que le marché n'a
pas d'influence sur les autres
transactions parce que on a un système
assez sophistiqué assez complexe qui
fait que les prix qui sont définis sur
ce marché qui couvre une petite partie
des transactions vont avoir une
influence sur la façon dont se passe les
transactions sur les autres segments
mais vous voyez que par exemple la reine
et son prix à 42 euros c'est plus en
soutirage
que la partie qui est vraiment négociée
sur le marché c'est un point important
et dans la partie des
transactions intra-groupes d'EDF la
reine qui est en miroir parce que il
faut savoir qu'il y a pas seulement les
fournisseurs alternatifs qui bénéficient
de la reine tous les consommateurs qui
sont au TRV et clients d'EDF bénéficient
également de la reine et dans des
conditions tout à fait analogues à
celles des fournisseurs alternatifs
donc tout ça fait que sur le marché
français il faut vraiment avoir en tête
que le marché est un outil qui est
essentiellement dédié
à organiser les échanges avec les autres
pays et je pense que c'est ça le point
majeur de ce qu'a dit Monsieur glachon
le marché européen ça d'abord été un
marché pour organiser au mieux les
échanges entre pays européens une grande
latitude étant laissée à chacun des pays
pour s'organiser en interne
donc c'est pas extraordinaire
on va peut-être avancer parce que alors
sur le voilà sur la frise du marché il
faut savoir qu'on est maintenant un
outil extrêmement sophistiqué ou on peut
distinguer des marchés à terme où là les
gens s'échangent de l'électricité avec
un terme à l'avenir
la liquidité existe en France jusqu'à
trois ans donc vous pouvez vous acheter
ou vendre de l'électricité à l'avance à
un prix déterminé à un horizon de trois
ans ces horizons sont un peu plus
importants en Allemagne ou il y a une
vraie liquidité pour des échéances un
peu plus lointaines mais on observe pas
et ça c'est un point très important on
observe pas de maturité qui serait
compatible conforme à ce que pourrait
souhaiter un investisseur qui va
investir dans un moyen de production
si vous voulez investir dans une
production d'électricité que ce soit du
renouvelable du nucléaire ou même des
moyens thermiques
une certaine mesure pour les moyens de
thermique vous avez besoin d'une
visibilité
sur vos recettes qu'aujourd'hui le
marché à terme ne donne pas
donc autrement dit moi je suis porteur
d'un projet d'investissement
renouvelable je m'adresse à mon banquier
pour essayer de le financer
le banquier va dire quels sont vos
perspectives de chiffre d'affaires sur
votre installation
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas conclure sur
le marché à terme des contrats qui ne
permettraient lui dire à mon banquier
que j'ai sécurisé mes recettes
cette faiblesse elle est compensée par
le développement
qui existe absolument dans tous les pays
européens de contrats de long terme
alors monsieur clachon a cité le contrat
de Friends parce que c'est celui qui est
le plus répandu avant lui en particulier
en France on a eu le régime des
obligations d'achat où on en
garantissait aux opérateurs
renouvelables l'achat de leur production
par une branche de déesse à un prix fixé
dans leur contrat
donc il faut bien avoir en tête que
c'est insuffisance dans le temps du
marché de gros actuel elle est compensée
par des contrats de long terme le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est d'élargir sans doute
ces contrats long terme
à d'autres formes d'énergie que les
seuls renouvelables
on en a parlé on va en reparler alors
pourquoi est-ce que ce sujet est à
l'ordre du jour parce que d'abord on a
constaté que
le marché à terme ne permettait pas de
sécuriser les revenus des gens qui
avaient des projets d'investissement
dans les moyens de production d'une part
et d'autre part les dispositifs en
particulier en France qui existait
ont une date de péremption le dispositif
de la Reine qui a organisé la vente de
l'électricité nucléaire par EDF à la
fois à ses clients je vous l'ai dit tout
à l'heure et à des fournisseurs
alternatifs de toute façon doit prendre
fin en 2025
et ce terme est un terme juridique il
faut donc remplacer la règle
donc il y a vraiment un sujet sur la
table en France qui est d'organiser un
futur pour la production nucléaire
compte tenu de la péremption du texte
qui l'organise aujourd'hui
on va peut-être alors pardon
non c'est bien c'est la slide
alors au-delà de ce marché à terme qui
qui a des échéances lointaines il y a
des outils de beaucoup plus court terme
qui essaye d'organiser au mieux
l'équilibrage de la demande et de
l'offre sur le marché électrique
français donc c'est ce qu'on appelle le
marché spot c'est ce qu'on appelle aussi
le marché infra journalier parce que
ensuite on rentre dans le détail alors
je vais pas rentrer dans le détail de
ces mécanismes extrêmement sophistiqués
ce qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est que
ces mécanismes ont un tout petit peu
fait quand même la preuve de leur
efficacité
puisque
on n'a pas eu
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
de vraies crises majeures d'équilibrage
alors même qu'on était dans une crise
profonde
donc moi je vais un peu revenir
là-dessus c'est le deuxième temps de mon
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui la crise
qu'on traverse c'est pas une crise
financière au sens où il y aurait un
emballement des marchés sans aucune
raison physique la crise que l'on
connaît c'est d'abord une crise
d'approvisionnement
et en France la crise
d'approvisionnement elle est un tout
petit peu différente de la crise
d'approvisionnement dans l'ensemble des
pays européens
on peut estimer en 2022 je cite ce
chiffre parce qu'on a beaucoup travaillé
à 800 terawattheure l'énergie qui ne
vient plus
n'avait pas line qu'on avait avec la
Russie donc du fait
de la de la guerre
et de l'invasion de l'Ukraine
on est privé en Europe le 84 de gaz
on a en France un problème très
spécifique de disponibilité du parc
nucléaire
qui a été révélé
en décembre 2021 par le groupe EDF donc
il a mentionné les difficultés et la
découverte du phénomène de corrosion
sous contrainte
quand on regarde l'ensemble de la
production nucléaire de cette année on
est pas encore tout à fait fini mais
bientôt
on peut estimer qui va manquer par
rapport à une année normale c'est-à-dire
celle observée auparavant le 80 à 100 et
Lawh de production nucléaire
donc en France on a deux crises
d'approvisionnement
on a la crise que on partage avec tous
les autres sur le gaz un peu moins que
les autres parce qu'on était moins
dépendants du gaz russe par Papeline que
d'autres pays mais on a une crise
d'approvisionnement associée aux
difficultés rencontrées sur le parc
nucléaire
la combinaison de ces deux éléments fait
que
c'est en France que les prix de
l'électricité ont le plus augmenté
c'est à dire quand on regarde la carte
des prix de l'électricité sur le marché
à terme alors là on peut peut-être
encore après voilà quand on regarde la
carte du marché du prix à terme de
l'électricité
on voit qu'en France c'est en France
qu'on a dépassé les 1000 euros
pour le prix de l'année 2023
et si on a dépassé les minéraux pour le
prix de l'année 2023 c'est pour la
raison que je vous ai indiqué c'est à
dire que en France on a une double crise
d'approvisionnement liée à la fois
au gaz et
à la disponibilité du parc nucléaire
alors j'avance très vite
ah oui bien sûr
sur la dessus
là dessus
oui bien sûr mais
là dessus voilà
là on est on a un problème avec 30
centrales
je continue et je vais
je vais terminer rapidement
donc on a une vraie crise
d'approvisionnement il faut voir que la
réponse
de l'organisation globale
ainsi malgré tout alors pour le gaz
certainement pour l'électricité c'est un
petit peu plus discutable
à un certain optimisme qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé
on a cette crise d'approvisionnement en
gaz les prix augmentent
les gens sont raisonnablement exposés en
Europe
au prix de marché du gaz qu'est-ce qu'on
constate on constate deux choses d'une
part des afflux de GNL nous on les a
mesuré on pense que sur les 800
terawattoirs de gaz qui manquent il y en
a 500 qui ont été compensés par le génl
donc les prix très élevés du gaz sur le
marché ont permis d'attirer des
cargaisons de GNL dans des proportions
extrêmement importantes et par ailleurs
on observe et c'est naturel puisque les
gens sont exposés au prix du gaz même en
France un peu parce que le bouclier
tarifaire sur le gaz il a été mis en
place après une augmentation assez
significative du prix du gaz
ce qu'on observe c'est une baisse de la
consommation de gaz
dans des proportions relativement
importantes qui posent des problèmes
d'avenir de compétitivité de la
de l'industrie européenne mais qui sur
le moment ont permis d'absorber la crise
d'approvisionnement donc le marché c'est
un outil qui a permis de passer
sur l'électricité
on observe malgré tout la même chose je
vous signale que RTE publie chaque
semaine un tableau très précis de
l'évolution de la consommation et qu'on
constate là aussi alors c'est très
concentré sur les gens qui sont exposés
au prix de marché de l'électricité c'est
à dire les industriels mais on constate
une forte baisse de la consommation
électrique
donc le marché c'est aussi quelque chose
qui permet d'absorber
dans d'assez bonnes conditions
les chocs considérables que nous avons
eu à affronter alors je finirai en
disant très rapidement que le sujet qui
est sur la table en tout cas pour
l'électricité c'est de lever les
préventions qui existaient
vis-à-vis des contrats de long terme qui
ont été vraiment prégnantes
de la part de la Commission européenne
et moi je suis d'un tempérament
optimiste je pense que cette levée des
préventions sur les contrats de long
terme pour différents types d'énergie
elle est en bonne voie
voilà merci beaucoup
merci de ces propos très très clairs on
verra peut-être sur le fait qui est
intéressant de la responsabilisation
finalement puisque on entend les
entreprises et c'est là-dessus que ça
c'est ciblé les entreprises ont eu une
forme d'autorégulation responsable
est-ce qu'il en est le même chez les
particuliers c'est aussi une réflexion
sans spoiler oui en partie
juste un point que que me semble-t-il
vous n'avez pas vous n'avez pas abordé
et puis les autres invités pourront
s'exprimer aussi par rapport à ça et
c'est un sujet évidemment qui nous tient
à cœur la la réforme du Market design ou
le Market design voilà
quelles sont les propositions dans quel
sens faut-il aller pour voilà je vous
dites que les choses si j'ai bien
compris vont se vont se résoudre pas
d'elle-même mais voilà vous êtes pas
allé jusque là mais voilà que ça rentre
dans l'ordre que ça va rentrer dans
l'ordre nous on se pose une question
fondamentale quant à la question de la
structuration notamment tarifaire et
l'organisation du marché voilà dans
quelle direction faut-il aller pour en
plus des choses qui suivront leur cours
éviter que être plus résilient si
d'aventure voilà des choses se
reproduisaient ou dans l'intérêt général
de de compétitivité européenne nationale
européenne
alors je réponds pas tout de suite mais
faute de temps j'ai pas développé ce
point là mais le point important que je
voulais mettre en avant sur cette
question du Market design
c'est vraiment le développement de
contrat de long terme
qui permettent aux investisseurs
d'investir dans la production d'énergie
c'est ça le point à mon avis qui est à
l'ordre du jour aujourd'hui
juste une question dessus liée donc la
question du que l'on évoque souvent
entre nous sans être aussi spécialiste
que que vous l'êtes la question du
découplage
du prix de l'électricité finalement
voilà des coups complets d'électricité
par rapport au gaz au gaz notamment
voilà quel est votre position par
rapport à ça au-delà de la mise en place
de contrats long terme
monsieur Monsieur Jacques persebois vous
êtes professeur émérite à l'Université
de Montpellier directeur du Centre de
recherche en économie et droit de
l'énergie donc je vous serais
reconnaissant d'aborder mais finalement
dans le cadre d'une conversation large
au-delà des dysfonctionnements du marché
l'impact des mesures d'urgence proposée
par la Commission européenne et de
présenter les pistes de réforme que vous
suggérez notamment pour protéger les
consommateurs vous avez récemment publié
un article remarqué dans lequel vous
proposez une réforme du système
Président Monsieur Elvis président
mesdames messieurs je vais en effet
peut-être insister sur les propositions
de réforme je pars d'un constat beaucoup
de choses ont déjà été dites le constat
c'est que la situation actuelle résulte
de phénomènes principaux d'une part en
effet la hausse du prix du gaz qui fait
que les centrales qui sont appelés en
fonction du méritorer sont des centrales
qui coûte plus cher en fonctionnement
puisque le coût du combustible joue un
rôle important et la deuxième raison
c'est le manque de capacité un manque de
capacité qui s'explique par fait qu'en
Europe depuis une quinzaine d'années on
a fermé beaucoup de capacités de
disponibles et notamment pilotables
c'est vrai pour les centrales à gaz
c'est vrai pour le nucléaire en
Allemagne c'est même vrai pour le
nucléaire en France donc on manque de
capacité dans un contexte où on pensait
que la demande d'électricité n'allait
pas n'allait pas augmenter et en fait on
s'aperçoit que ce manque de capacité
aujourd'hui est une est une contrainte
forte sur les marchés européens alors on
constate quand même que le prix
d'équilibre sur le marché de gros et
souvent supérieur au coût marginal de la
centrale à gaz donc ça veut bien dire
qu'il y a à la fois je dirais une prime
de risque voir un peu de spéculation
c'est très difficile de savoir quelle
est la part qui relève des de ces deux
observations mais il faut quand même
observer que si le prix du gars le prix
de l'électricité corrélé auprès du
Gaspard indexé certains des indexés il
est pas indexé il est simplement corrélé
cette corrélation fait que le prix de
l'électricité est souvent très supérieur
au coût marginal je t'explique
d'ailleurs qu'en France le prix gros
soit supérieur à ce qu'on trouve dans
d'autres pays et notamment en Allemagne
je rappelle quand même que le prix gros
ce n'est qu'une partie du prix de
détails au départ c'est de c'est un
tiers sur l'ensemble du du prix de
détail si je prends le TRV alors ne
parlons pas évidemment des taxes ni de
du coup des réseaux aujourd'hui c'est
plus parce qu'évidemment le coup de
fourniture ayant monté on est plus
proche de 40-45% y compris y compris en
France alors je crois qu'il faut
dissocier les réformes de court terme
les solutions court terme et les
solutions de long terme alors je vais un
peu aborder ça dans le court terme puis
ensuite ce qui est peut-être un peu plus
un peu plus pérenne alors parmi un parmi
ces solutions la première à laquelle on
peut penser qui d'ailleurs fait un peu
ses preuves c'est tout en maintenant
tout à fait le système c'est compter sur
une réduction de la demande
d'électricité le prix augmentant cela
favorise aussi l'efficacité au niveau
des usages donc la baisse de la demande
qui a été évoquée qui est relativement
important puisque RTE parle de 6 à 7 %
ce qui est pas négligeable cette baisse
de la demande peut paraître est une
bonne chose ça peut aussi refléter un
problème si cette baisse de la demande
tient au fait qu'il y a des failliettes
d'entreprises ou des arrêts de
production au pire des délocalisations
certaines entreprises européennes
annonçant déjà qu'elles vont aller
s'implanter aux États-Unis donc la
baisse de la demande il faut être très
très prudent sur la façon dont on
analyse une deuxième solution qui a pu
être évoquée mais qui à mon sens est pas
efficace c'est de dire le système actuel
fait que le prix d'équilibre
s'applique à tout le monde même si le
marché de gros ne représente ça a été
évoqué qu'une faible part des
transactions parce qu'il y a du hors
marché important
il faut bien observer que et bien c'est
la logique du marché que chacun reçoit
le prix d'équilibre il y a donc des
rentes infra marginales qui aujourd'hui
sont très importantes puisque le prix
gros est très très élevé alors certains
disent bah il faudrait faire des
enchères non pas à prix limite comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui mais des
enchères a pris une mandé c'est-à-dire
non pas des enchères à la française mais
la Hollandaise ce que l'État utilise par
exemple pour les obligations
assimilables du trésor ce système peut
marcher dans un contexte où l'offre est
excédentaire ça marche pas dans un
contexte où on est en pénurie ou une
offre insuffisante parce que tout le
monde anticipe évidemment ce que sera le
prix d'équilibre donc personne ne va
faire des propositions de ça je dirais
d'un prix relativement élevé la
troisième solution c'est une solution
que j'ai regardé avec un collègue du CEA
bon c'est c'est un peu académique c'est
de proposer la moyenne des coûts
marginaux avec compensation pour la
centrale marginale l'avantage c'est que
ça fait baisser évidemment fortement le
prix d'équilibre alors évidemment les
centrales qui sont au dessus de la
moyenne couvre pas leur coût variable
mais c'est pas gênant on leur donne une
compensation et comme ça fait baisser
beaucoup le prix d'équilibre et bien la
rente inframarginale le baisse fortement
alors ce système n'évalide que dans un
système que dans un contexte où le coup
marginal est extrêmement élevé par
rapport aux autres cours marginaux
c'est-à-dire que si on regarde les
centrales renouvelables ou si on regarde
les centrales nucléaires elles sont très
Anxa donc ça fait baisser la moyenne
donc ça c'est très efficace en France ça
serait pas nécessairement dans un autre
contexte ou dans un pays où ce serait
pas le cas il y a d'autres solutions qui
ont été évoquées je trouve que c'est une
solution très séduisante c'est la
solution qu'on appelle hispanique c'est
à dire
de subventionner le gaz utilisé dans la
production d'électricité
ça fait baisser le prix en Espagne
puisque alors c'est vrai que le poids du
gaz en Espagne est relativement élevé
dans la production de l'électricité mais
si vous regardez les prix de gros sur le
marché espagnol au minimum deux fois
moins moindre que le prix sur le reste
de l'Europe
il y a des effets pervers parce
qu'évidemment ça peut relancer un peu la
demande de gaz ça peut être appliqué en
Espagne parce que les interconnexions
entre l'Espagne et le Portugal d'un côté
et le reste de l'Europe sont pas très
très importantes et donc il y a pas trop
de fuite il y en a eu quand même parce
que certains opérateurs espagnols ont
préféré vendre sur le marché français ou
c'était beaucoup plus rémunérateur mais
cette solution à court terme paraît
extrêmement séduisante même si ça peut
relancer la demande de gaz même si ça
résout pas le problème des industriels
qui utilisent du gaz pour d'autres
raisons je pense que pour ma part à
court terme si on veut éteindre
l'incendie c'est une solution qui est
qui est tout à fait justifiée alors les
allemands n'en veulent pas ils en
veulent pas parce qu'ils pensent qu'à
leur coûterait trop cher pour eux et en
plus la subventionnerait le consommateur
français puisqu'il nous vendent beaucoup
d'électricité thermique une grande
partie du temps et notamment aux heures
pleines et donc ils auraient le
sentiment que c'est le consommateur
allemand qui va financer le consommateur
français alors on peut autre solution
taxer la rentrée marginale c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui a été évoqué en disant
ben écoutez au-delà de 180 euros le
mégawattheure sur le marché électrique
je prends tout bon pourquoi pas alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de cette rente qui
est captée on peut soit l'utiliser en
effet pour aider les centrales à gaz ça
a été revenir à la solution précédente
soit pour aider les consommateurs soit
le consommateur domestique soit le
consommateur industriel c'est une
solution séduisante
c'est visiblement ce que préfère les
Allemands mais en France il faut pas
perdre de vue que cette rentrée
marginale serait probablement moins
élevée pour deux raisons parce qu'on a
beaucoup d'électricité qui est vendu un
prix régulé on a cité le nucléaire le
nucléaire est vendu très largement très
régulier c'est la reine alors c'est la
reine dont profite évidemment les
alternatives mais c'est aussi la reine
qu'on retrouve dans le TRV si elle est
fait miroir dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure c'est à dire qu'en fait une
grande partie de l'électricité française
est vendu à un prix un prix régulé qui
est proche donc qui est proche donc des
42 euros par mégawattheure mais cette
solution alors l'autre élément c'est que
les renouvelables elles sont également
vendues un prix régulé puisque c'est
soit définie tarifs des prix d'achat
garantie sur une certaine période soit
c'est un système je dirais de
compensation complément de complément de
rémunération donc le complément de
rémunération était séduisant pour les
producteurs de renouvelables tant que et
bien le prix de gros était peu élevé et
inférieur en tout cas au coût de
production il bénéficier en effet d'un
complément de rémunération mais ce
complément de rémunération est devenu
négatif et donc ça a été rappelé je
crois qu'on estime que pour l'année 2022
2023 ça devrait rapporter plus de 30
milliards on parle même de 38 milliards
d'euros donc c'est relativement
important donc on peut avoir un
complément un complément négatif
alors un prix plafond pour le gaz oui à
condition que les vendeurs de gaz
acceptent je dirais la négociation à ce
prix plafond pourquoi pas il y a une
autre solution qui me paraîtrait
séduisante alors là on va plutôt vers le
moyen de volontaire c'est la réforme qui
me paraît importante sur sur le moyen
long terme c'est le système que certains
appellent le système grec qui consiste à
faire deux compartiments sur le marché
gros un compartiment avec les centrales
à forte proportion de coût fixe forte
apex d'un côté c'est-à-dire
essentiellement les renouvelables et le
nucléaire parce que là ce sont les coûts
fixes qui sont le point important il y a
très peu de coût variables les centrales
renouvelables c'est quasiment zéro et le
nucléaire c'est 5% ou 7%, ça dépend
comment on compte et l'autre
compartiment c'est un compartiment qui
resterait le compartiment ou le prix
serait fixé par et bien le mériteur
d'air fondé sur les coûts marginaux
c'est-à-dire le coût variable c'est le
cas des centrales au charbon mais bien
évidemment surtout centrale à gaz alors
l'avantage du système c'est que sur la
gauche sur la partie des centrales
renouvelables et nucléaires le prix
serait fixé par appel d'offres sur la
base du coût moyen et sur la partie
droite les fossiles le prix sera fixé
sur la base du coup marginal
c'est-à-dire les coûts variables et le
consommateur paierait un prix qui serait
une moyenne pondérée des deux à court
terme ça peut régler une partie du
problème même si le système est un peu
compliqué à mettre en oeuvre car pour
l'instant c'est le principe l'avantage
c'est qu'il est pérenne sur le long
terme parce qu'au fur et à mesure que
les centrales fossiles vont se vont
disparaître et bien le système peut
rester c'est-à-dire que c'est la
frontière entre les deux compartiments
qui va bouger et donc à terme ça veut
dire que et bien le le prix serait calé
sur le coût moyen des centrales à fort
ou fixe et ça je crois que c'est un bon
système alors ça m'amène en effet à une
solution que personnellement pour le
long terme je privilégie c'est une
solution proche de l'acheteur unique
c'est-à-dire d'un système que la France
avait proposé au moment au début de la
libéralisation alors aujourd'hui ce
serait probablement incompatible avec
les textes européens mais c'est un
système très séduisant parce que ça veut
dire qu'on fait un appel des différentes
centrales et qu'on peut proposer des
contrats à long terme avec les
producteurs qui sont retenus donc le
prix serait aligné sur le coût moyen sur
sur le long terme alors je parle pas de
la dernière solution que certains
évoquent qui consiste à dire on supprime
le marché on revient au monopole public
intégré je crois que le marché a un
atout parce que même avec le système en
effet d'un acheteur unique on peut avoir
un marché sur le très court terme et un
marché
au niveau des frontières c'est-à-dire
que le marché est incitatif il envoie
des bons signaux de court terme il en
voit pas les signaux de long terme donc
de toute façon il faudra faire une
réforme sur le long terme pour une
raison simple
c'est que demain si nous avons un mix
qui est constitué uniquement de
nucléaire et de renouvelables ce qui
caractérisera ces centrales c'est que la
part des coûts est très élevé la part
des coût variable est très faible donc
de toute façon le prix devrait être calé
sur le coût moyen donc je l'ai on peut
dès aujourd'hui avec le système qu'on
appelle un peu par extension le système
grec aller vers un système où bien avec
des contrats long terme et un prix calé
sur le coût moyen on envoie un signal
qui fait que le prix est relativement
stable et couvre les coûts complets des
centrales je vous remercie
si Monsieur percebot alors maintenant
nous allons regarder la télévision
puisque nous avons en visio conférence
Monsieur Christian Ruby qui est
secrétaire général de l'Association
européenne des énergéticiens eurent
électrique
pouvez-vous nous apporter monsieur si
vous nous entendez bien un petit geste
de la tête parfait allez-y parler pour
voir si tout fonctionne
bonjour et merci beaucoup pour la
méditation je m'appelle Christian je
suis les secrétaire général de
électrique quand vous avez dit c'est
l'association qui représente les
intérêts de l'industrie électrique on
est bio européenne à notre secteur et de
ferment engagé dans la transition
énergétique avec les objectifs
d'attendre une fourniture d'électricité
à neutre en carbone d'ici
2045 ou plus tard
l'industrie électrique vise à être un
acteur central de la bicarbonisation de
nos sociétés grâce à une électrification
directe et indirecte des suissages dans
les secteurs clés de l'économie tel que
les transports les bâtiments l'industrie
à nos membres sont associations
nationales qui représentent l'industrie
électrique et nous représentants ainsi
prêts
en France nous parlons au nom de
ufe
alors le marché intérieur d'électricité
a pour finalité d'offrir une réelle
liberté de choix à tous les
consommateurs de l'Union des
intensifier les échanges
transfrontaliers de manière à réaliser
des progrès en termes
d'efficacité et attendre des prix
compétitifs et c'est important de
comprendre des
en période normale le marché intérieur
d'électricité d'électricité atténue ses
promesses
le marché a renforcé la concurrence et
on a vu beaucoup à des bénéfices de chez
changes transparentes alliés et
les bénéfices pour les consommateurs
sans les B à environ de
34 milliards d'euros en 2021 alors
ça c'est important de savoir quand on
parle des réformes
même pendant la crise énergétique
actuelle le marché intérieur à prouver
en fait sa robustesse pendant la flambée
des prix l'énergie
mais aussi nous ne pouvons pas innover
l'impact de la flambée des prix de
l'énergie sur des consommateurs final et
industrielle
et il s'est super important
qu'on séparés ici qu'on dit il y a des
choses structurelles qu'on doit changer
peut-être mais il y a aussi des choses à
court terme on doit les séparer quand on
fait la politique et les règles
et c'est pour ça on dit maintenant
dans cette situation on doit focuser
aux consommateurs vulnérables et mettre
des messieurs pour les et pour les
réformes structurales on doit se
orienter
aux objectifs long terme pour Europe
alors
au point de vue de réélectrique on a
besoin d'une ébullition du marché pas
une révolution on doit avoir des
investissements en environ de 100
milliards d'euros chaque année jusqu'à
2000 150 alors
c'est super important avec la confiance
des investisseurs
bon la réforme du marché intérieur
d'électricité à lancer par la Commission
doit donc ici trop tarder protéger les
principes fondamentaux actuels et
poursuivre les efforts d'intégration
des marchés court terme
mais si on voit aussi qu'est-ce qu'on
fait avec les investissements parce que
il y a une situation où on a besoin des
signaux long terme aussi
alors nous disons électriques
que ce sera important
de
assurer aussi que les consommateurs
bénéfices davantage des investissements
dans les technologies renouvelables et
bacarbonne
et pour cela électrique recommande que
la réforme des marchés d'électricité
s'appuient sur le modèle existant du
marché intérieur de l'énergie et y
ajoute trois éléments essentiels un
cadre contractuel amélioré pour les
consommateurs permettant des
possibilités suffisantes des couvertures
et de contrats long terme
un cadre pour faciliter les
investissements nécessaires à la tente
des objectifs
notamment pour les technologies à forte
intensité de capital et en cadre
facilitant
[Musique]
et coordination des besoins du système
électrique pour garantir la décation et
la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et répondant à
l'ébullition des besoins du système
pour l'instant on finalise une étude
électrique pour détailler ces
recommandations merci beaucoup
merci Monsieur
on va passer maintenant Monsieur Didier
hollow qui est président de l'Union
européenne de l'industrie du gaz naturel
euro gaz
et c'est en ce nom qui va s'exprimer je
pense mathildy mais parce qu'il est
aussi également directeur général
adjoint du groupe engie et il va nous
apporter les visions des acteurs du gaz
dans le contexte actuel mot qu'on a
entendu répéter au moins une centaine de
fois depuis le début de cette réunion
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
mesdames et messieurs je parlerai
effectivement au nom de vos gaz
aujourd'hui j'ai peut-être commencé par
notre vision de de la crise de l'énergie
aujourd'hui
ce qui rebondira quand est complètement
les propos de
de nos orateurs notamment les
économistes qui sont autour de la table
et que je salue avec d'autant plus de
respect que je ne suis pas moi-même
économiste
nous avons une vision qui est qu'il y a
en fait deux crises de l'énergie une de
l'électricité une du gaz qui sont très
largement
corrélées par moments par moment assez
fortement décorrélé selon les endroits
et contrairement à ce que certaines
expressions peuvent laisser entendre de
temps à autre ça n'est pas le gaz qui
est responsable du prix de l'électricité
mais c'est très largement aussi le prix
de l'électricité qui est responsable du
prix du gaz
je vais commencer par la crise de la de
la demande de gaz qui fait monter les
prix à partir de 2021 elle est liée en
partie à des facteurs purement liés au
gaz l'hiver a été froid les stockage
sont vides à la sortie de l'hiver il
faut les remplir
mais elle est aussi liée à des
phénomènes électriques et en particulier
la sécheresse en Amérique du Sud la
sécheresse en Amérique du Sud fait que
le Brésil importe du GNL comme il ne l'a
jamais fait que le Chili apporte du GNL
pourquoi parce qu'il faut produire avec
les centrales à gaz pour compenser
l'absence de production hydraulique
et cette demande supplémentaire est un
des facteurs importants de la montée des
prix du gaz en 2021 avant que pendant
l'été la Russie ne prenne le relais en
ne mettant pas de gaz sur le marché
court terme et qu'un certain nombre
d'autres phénomènes viennent s'amplifier
mais je rappelle aussi que sur ce même
été 2021 la faiblesse du vent en Europe
fait que les centrales éoliennes
produisent moins et que là aussi on fait
tourner des centrales à gaz en période
d'été ce qui est relativement rare parce
que normalement en période d'été les
centrales à gaz sont très largement
inutilisés et donc cette demande
supplémentaire de gaz contribue à la
montée des prix sur toute l'année 2021
des prix du gaz deuxième élément qui
montre que les
prix du gaz et de l'électricité sont
corrélés mais que les crises sont dans
une certaine mesure indépendante
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez le
marché forward sur des marchés comme la
France mais aussi dans une certaine
mesure la Belgique ou l'Allemagne etc ce
qu'on appelle le clean Spark spread
c'est à dire la différence de coût
marginal entre le prix de l'électricité
et le coût du gaz que vous mettez dans
une centrale à gaz il est très largement
positif sur ces marchés ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui au vu des marchés à terme
pour l'année 2023 que ça soit d'ailleurs
l'été où l'hiver
de l'électricité du gaz si vous avez une
centrale à gaz vous avez intérêt à
vendre votre électricité à terme et à
acheter votre gaz à terme ce qui fait
monter le prix du gaz à terme sur cette
sur cette année-là donc voilà je vous
voudrais vraiment insister là-dessus les
deux crises ont une forte corrélation
mais qui joue dans les deux sens et
elles sont largement indépendantes
l'autre preuve de l'indépendance et ça a
été souligné par Monsieur Ménard c'est
que les prix du gaz et de l'électricité
sont en sens inverse entre la France et
l'Allemagne c'est à dire que depuis le
début de la crise le prix du gaz est
plus faible en France qu'en Allemagne de
l'ordre de 20 à 40 euros par
mégawattheure et les prix de
l'électricité sont plus forts en
Allemagne qu'en France de l'ordre de 70
jusqu'à 200 euros puisque au moment où
les prix étaient au dessus de 1000 euros
en France ils étaient à 800 et quelques
en Allemagne
donc voilà le fait qu'il y ait une
certaine corrélation entre les prix ne
veut pas dire qu'il y a pas deux crises
séparées
et je reviens là aussi sur ce qu'elle
dit Monsieur Ménard mais aussi monsieur
perso bois les prix aujourd'hui sur le
marché du gaz l'électricité sont assez
largement supérieures à ce que serait le
prix d'équilibre qui assure l'équilibre
entre l'offre et la demande pourquoi
parce que
il y a manque de confiance et il y a
très faible liquidités du marché c'est à
dire un les gens ne croient pas aux
fondamentaux et là il faut quand même le
dire nous avons à faire face à une
situation où les gens se disent mais on
nous a tellement raconté que telle
centrale serait disponible et elle n'est
pas finalement que moi si j'ai une
certaine longueur c'est-à-dire si j'ai
plus d'électricité que je n'en vends je
la garde parce que je ne sais pas ce qui
va se passer même chose sur le gaz et
donc ces phénomènes de manque de
confiance dans la liquidité du marché
génère une prime de risque et moi
j'appelle ça une prime de risque et
c'est pas une valeur spéculative les
gens ont peur ils ont d'autant plus de
raisons d'avoir peur que si vous vous
retrouvez court sur le marché vous
pouvez aller à la faillite comme une
hyper qui a perdu 40 milliards
donc il faut être conscient de ce fait
dernière chose malheureusement tout le
monde dit oui la demande s'est ajustée
nous en tant que gazier nous disons nous
faisons une distinction entre ce qu'on
appelle la réduction de la demande et la
destruction de la demande la réduction
de la demande c'est simple c'est quand
on fait un effort pour chauffer moins
chez soi que on fait un effort pour
moins consommer partout où on peut
l'éviter raisonnablement ou on fait plus
d'efficacité énergétique la destruction
de la demande c'est quand nos clients
s'arrêtent de fonctionner parce qu'ils
ne peuvent plus se payer les prix et
quand on me dit les prix font le marché
fonctionne
parce que il a toujours donné un prix et
que il s'est équilibré quand les clients
ne peuvent plus payer le prix est-ce que
on peut considérer que le marché
fonctionne c'est une c'est une question
qui doit rester ouverte alors
dernier point sur le long terme je
voudrais rappeler ici que
le gaz est un facteur important pour
éviter les pointes d'électricité à la
fois pour les fournir quand il y en a
besoin c'est-à-dire les centrales à gaz
fournissent la pointe ultime
d'électricité mais je rappelle qu'avec
des dispositifs du que ça soit les
réseaux de chaleur qui ont un certain
choix sur leur énergie ou que ça soit
les pompes à chaleur hybrides par
exemple vous avez des outils qui
permettent que quand on est très proche
de la pointe de demande électrique on
bascule sur le gaz qui lui a des
capacités de stockage ce qui permet
d'avoir un effet modérateur sur les prix
marginaux de l'électricité il est
important de le rappeler ici aussi alors
réforme des prix la position de regard
c'est de dire le mécanisme ibérique
c'est un mécanisme beaucoup plus cher
qu'il n'y paraît dont il a pu
fonctionner dans le contexte ibérique
parce que les échanges tant de gaz et
d'électricité avec le reste du marché
sont limités
il serait très difficile à appliquer à
l'échelle européenne et surtout on ne
sait pas très bien combien ça coûterait
en réalité quel serait l'impact sur les
prix donc nous le prenons avec
extrêmement de prudence
à cause de ses effets de bord
de ces problèmes de coup
S qui serait très élevé probablement
pour l'État tout ce qui concerne la
réduction de prix pour les clients alors
évidemment la réduction de prix pour les
clients vulnérables est une évidence la
réduction de prix pour les entreprises
on le sait pose des problèmes de
distorsion d'un pays à l'autre elle pose
des problèmes de coût et nous insistons
surtout sur le fait que ce ne sont pas
les entreprises gazières qui peuvent le
financer
parce que
si on se trouve à devoir vendre à perte
d'une part c'est illégal et d'autre part
ça conduit les entreprises dans une
situation de faillite encore une fois
l'exemple une hyper le montre donc
il faut vraiment
réfléchir à la fois des systèmes qui ne
distordent pas l'intro la concurrence
entre pays et d'autre part à des
systèmes dans lesquels le coût
budgétaire soit à peu près maîtrisé et à
ce moment-là les entreprises gazières
peuvent bien entendu contribuer
c'est ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
sur le bouclier tarifaire puisque de
fait ce sont les fournisseurs gaziers
par exemple qui avancent la différence
de prix puisqu'il en achète sur le
marché de gros et on vend au prix au
prix fixé par le bouclier tarifaire avec
la promesse que l'État nous compensera à
un moment donné
je souligne néanmoins que ceux-ci
représente à la fois un effort en
trésorerie tout à fait conséquent pour
les entreprises et à peu près tous les
régimes de
soutien au prix aux consommateurs ont un
impact de trésorerie très important pour
les entreprises à un moment où leurs
interventions sur le marché des appels
avoir aussi des appels de marge qui se
chiffre en milliard voire en dizaines de
milliards et donc cette situation de
marché
conduit les entreprises énergétiques les
entreprises gazières notamment à avoir
des normes
besoins de cash que ce soit les appels
de marge le fonds de roulement ou le
financement des dispositifs de type
bouclier tarifaires et que quand on
parle de profit d'un côté il faut pas
négliger des risques économiques qui
sont associés
sur la rente infra marginale
euro gaz n'est pas enthousiaste à l'idée
de la capture de la rente infra
marginale mais on reconnaît que dans une
situation de crise comme celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui il est assez
logique que il soit demandé un effort
sur les moyens de production qui
produisent
à des coûts très inférieurs à au coûts
qui sont actuellement ceux sur le marché
alors
sur ce qui concerne plus spécifiquement
les moyens pour conclure
les moyens de production à gaz comme la
dit Monsieur Glachant il est nécessaire
bien souvent de compléter le mécanisme
de marché par des mécanismes de capacité
de
financement de capacité parce que
l'appel des centrales à gaz selon les
scénarios et trop aléatoires pour
permettre une rémunération raisonnable
de l'investissement dans certains nos
scénarios les centrales à gaz perdent de
l'argent cette année sur 8 et n'en gagne
que la 8ème année elles en gagnent
beaucoup quand elles en gagnent donc
normalement ça devrait s'équilibrer mais
je ne connais pas l'investisseur qui
investissent sur un tel business model
en conclusion deux mots
deux crises indépendante même si elles
sont corrélées changement de système de
rémunération pourquoi pas mais à ce
moment-là il faut laisser aux
entreprises le temps de s'adapter et
aussi considérer que les entreprises qui
ont investi dans un certains cadre
réglementaire si on leur change
complètement leur cadre il faut tenir
compte des conséquences économiques que
ça pour elle merci
bien maintenant nous allons donner la
parole à la Commission européenne au
travers madame sicomani qui est
directrice de la transition verte et
intégration du système énergétique à la
direction générale de l'énergie de la
commission vous êtes en visioconférence
madame Sico many où nous entendez bien
je le vois
allez-y vous pouvez vous exprimer une
petite dizaine de minutes pour que nous
laissions la parole à nos collègues et
notamment rapporteur Daniel Granier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
vice-président mesdames messieurs ravi
d'être ici avec vous à travers un
visioconférence de Bruxelles
le terme crise
urgence très fortes très utilisés
aujourd'hui en effet le secteur de
l'énergie est fortement impacté par
plusieurs facteurs aujourd'hui comme
nous avons entendu donc d'abord il y a
le retour de la croissance post covid il
y a des perturbations de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement
cet été était très sec qui a impacté les
hydro à production de hydro et il y a un
disponibilité des nucléaire aussi bien
en France qu'en Finlande et bien sûr il
y a la guerre en Ukraine qui tousse
impact fortement le marché de gaz et par
ricochet cellules d'électricité
également donc les prix ont augmenté et
l'approvisionnement en énergie semble
menacer à cet hiver
ces défis se font sentir dans l'ensemble
de l'Union européenne et une réponse
rapide et coordonnée à l'échelle de
l'Union européenne est nécessaire donc
les mesures nationales différentes qui
impactent la fonctionnement des marchés
peuvent avoir un silence négative sur la
sécurité
en octobre comme nous avons discuté ce
matin à la suite de la proposition de la
Commission le Conseil adopter un
règlement relatif à une intervention
d'urgence pour faire face au prix élevé
de l'énergie ce règlement temporaire qui
est d'application aujourd'hui à partir
d'aujourd'hui vise à réduire la demande
d'électricité et à atténuer les prix
élevés ceci vit à l'introduction d'abord
d'un plafond applicable au revenu un
freinage le 180 euros à une combination
combinée pour contribution pardon des
solidarités sur les bénéfices
excédentaires des secteurs de pétrole du
gaz et du charbon et des raffineries et
une redistribution de ces revenus ou
soutenir les consommateurs finaux aussi
bien à les ménages que les compagnies
donc ces mesures contribueront à rendre
l'électricité plus avortable et
constitue un premier pas vers les
travaux complémentaires en cours qui
vise à améliorer l'organisation à long
terme du marché de l'électricité
en effet la crise que nous traversons
rend autant plus urgent la nécessité des
décarboner et d'accélérer l'utilisation
des sources d'énergie renouvelable et à
faible émission de carbone c'est ça qui
est la solution pour la question des
couplages quand nous n'avons pas une
grande partie de l'électricité produite
par les fossiles ou par le gaz à nous
avons à atteindre le découpage
à côté des mesures d'urgence que je
viens de parcourir rapidement la
Commission poursuit les travaux sur
l'optimisation de fonctionnement du
marché européen
le marché de l'électricité a prouvé sur
ces derniers décennies sont efficacités
avec une fourniture fiable et des prix
bas les discussions se focaliser
d'ailleurs alors sur le problème des
revenus trop bas pour les producteurs en
anglais on parlait de missing Mani donc
l'argent qui manque
et aujourd'hui on peut aussi voir que la
France qui était un des grands
exportateurs de l'électricité au niveau
européen est devenu un pays importateur
et ceci grâce au marché de l'une l'Union
européenne et le découpage à des marchés
nationaux
entre temps la crise énergétique dont
nous connaissons tous l'ampleur a révélé
d'autres questions qui méritent d'être
adressée en complément et en relie des
mesures d'urgence donc c'est très forme
envisager pour le début de l'année 2023
et sur laquelle nous réfléchissons
aujourd'hui devra être ciblés à afin
d'avoir afin de pouvoir être mise en
oeuvre rapidement
cette réforme pourrait se concentrer sur
quatre aspects
premièrement les producteurs importent
particulières et nouvelles mais aussi de
nucléaires doivent avoir un revenu
prévisible stable afin d'encourager les
investissements nécessaires à inclus
aussi investissement dans la flexibilité
cela permettrait aussi de stabiliser les
prix et éviter une trop forte volatilité
pour le consommateur
l'améliorer l'amélioration de la
liquidité des marchés à terme est un
élément clé ainsi que la
contractualisation des nouveaux projets
énergies à via des contrats stables
les copanalistes ont déjà mentionné le
contrats pour différences et les pipi
qui sont à tous les deux des outils très
utiles
deuxièmement la réforme devrait
contribuer à dissocier autant que
possible les factures d'électricité des
ménages et des entreprises des prix du
gaz les contrats pour la différence les
PPA contribuent certainement à cette
objective mais il y en a d'autres pistes
que nous sommes en train de étudier en
ce moment même
troisièmement il est important de
préserver une utilisation efficace des
ressources à travers l'Europe afin de
garantir que l'électricité nécessaire
est toujours produite par la technologie
la moins chère disponible que l'offre et
la demande sont maintenus en équilibre à
chaque moment il est il est cependant
important de développer davantage les
moyens de flexibilité et notamment les
effacements de consommation et de
stockage
ceci pourrait avoir un impact direct sur
la consommation de gaz et ainsi sur le
prix de l'électricité
et enfin les consommateurs doivent être
mieux protégés il devrait disposer d'un
éventail d'offres y compris des contrats
à prix fixes
davantage de possibilités d'investir
directement dans la production et
d'énergie renouvelable pour le propre
usage et davantage de possibilités de
participer passion active sur le marché
la protection de consommateurs
vulnérable et particulièrement
importante et nous sommes en train de
aussi analyser comment définir une
consommation minimum qui devrait être
garantie à tout consommateur un prix
abordable
dans ce cadre de réforme et en plus
général allemand nous devons être sûr
que le marché fonctionne
d'une manière transparente et qu'il y a
en surveillance à quotidien à tout
moment donc nous sommes aussi en train
de voir comment améliorer le cadre qui
dit et à qui s'appelle rennit qui est
pour la transparence et la surveillance
à juste deux mots pour clôture clôturer
sur le processus donc la première étape
consistera à pour nous à publier une
document de consultation à avant à Noël
donc dans les quelques jours qui suivent
et nous attendons avec un grand intérêt
de toutes les contributions françaises
et autres pour cette consultation sur la
base de cette consultation nous avons
aussi travaillé sur un document de
travail qui explique les choix que la
Commission va faire
en proposant une
avant de tabler une proposition
législative à dans le début
2023 la date n'a pas été fixée pour
cette proposition mais il doit être fait
certainement avant le Conseil européen
qui aura lieu à la deuxième moitié de
mars donc en fonction des collisateurs
de telles modifications ciblées de
l'organisation de marché peuvent être
proposés rapidement et mises aussi mise
en oeuvre aussi rapidement
elle apporterait apporterait une
solution plus permanente à la dépendance
excessive des factures d'électricité
européenne à l'égard des marchés du gaz
naturel hautement volatiles aujourd'hui
et apporterait au consommateur des
avantages des coûts plus bas à des
énergies renouvelables et nucléaires en
fonction de leur part dans le bouquet
électrique merci
merci beaucoup madame de à la fois de
votre concision et de votre précision
j'ai bien noté qu'une consultation
allait être lancée mais juste avant Noël
donc il va falloir que nous soyons
attentifs les uns et les autres pour
écrire répondre éventuellement
voilà je passe la parole à Franck
Montauville s'il veut ajouter quelque
chose et commencer
juste par rapport au calendrier qui
viennent de nous être indiqués
d'y recueillir on a une discussion en
commission qui nous a amené
envisager
la rédaction d'une proposition de
résolution européenne qui trouverait
parfaitement je dirais sur l'intérêt
dans le cadre du calendrier qui a été
évoqué je passe la parole à
à Daniel grimillet qui est rapporteur de
la commission sur ces questions
d'énergie
et merci monsieur le Président
remercier l'ensemble nos madame et
Messieurs les
invités nous intervenants pour la clarté
effectivement de leur intervention
je souhaiterais vous poser trois points
de vue enfin trois sujets le premier qui
concerne évidemment le nucléaire
l'énergie nucléaire la moitié des États
membres dispose d'une part de deux d'un
parc de 2e génération et un quart
est engagé dans la construction de
réacteurs de troisième génération au
niveau de la Communauté européenne or la
taxonomie et défavorable à l'énergie
nucléaire qui est assimilée un activité
de transition comme le gaz et non une
activité durable comme les autres
énergies et des carbonées
par ailleurs les délais et les
conditions opposées sont impraticables
pour accompagner la relance du nucléaire
en France ne devrait-on pas lever ces
verrous par ailleurs le financement des
nouveaux réacteurs est très divers en
Europe avec le regroupement
d'entreprises et ergots intensive dans
un consortium en Finlande des prêts
étanatiques ou intérêts
tchèque des fonds propres en
contrepartie d'un prix de long terme
fixe ou réguler au Royaume-Uni avez-vous
identifié un mode de financement
préférentiel et pour terminer sur le
sujet du nucléaire je pense qu'on aura
du mal à comprendre si jamais la France
devait être condamnée
à plusieurs centaines de millions on
parle de 500 millions parce que nous
sommes en retard sur les EnR alors que
la France est en avance
elle est largement en tête de tous les
pays de l'Union européenne sur l'énergie
la plus décarbonée je le dis parce que
il y a quelques dizaines d'années
nous étions à 88% d'énergie complètement
décarbonée dans notre pays
le deuxième sujet c'est
l'hydroélectricité s'agissant de la
grande hydroélectricité la France est
sous le coup de contentieux qui dure
depuis là aussi longtemps maintenant on
va parler en décennie avec la Commission
européenne n'est pas la seule dans cette
situation puisque cet autre pays
européen sont concernés dans l'Allemagne
l'Italie 400 concessions échu ont été
placés en France sur le régime
transitoire dit des délais de 10 ans
c'est-à-dire qu'elles ont été prolongées
aux conditions antérieures sous réserve
de l'application d'une redevance la
crise énergétique actuelle
pas conduire sur ce sujet à un
appréhension moins stricte du principe
de concurrence ne faudrait-il pas
réviser à terme la directive
concession du 26 février 2014 pour en
exclure les concessions hydroélectriques
quant à la petite électrocexister elle
prenne plus être considérées comme une
énergie renouvelable subventionnelle
dans la directive sur les énergies
renouvelables en cours de négociation
n'est-ce pas perdre ici un levier de
décarbonation très ancré dans nos
territoires le troisième point que je
souhaiterais évoquer c'est le stockage
de l'électricité car les énergies
renouvelables pêchent toujours par une
leur intermittent et on en a eu
l'exemple tout à l'heure je vous
remercie vraiment parce que
effectivement la crise énergétique n'a
pas démarré avec la guerre en Ukraine
mais à bien commencer en 2021 et pour
des raisons parfois de compensation par
rapport et on l'a vécu aussi en France
au mois de décembre 2021 avec une grande
fragilité de production au niveau des
ENR qui nous a mis dans des situations
très très fragile
donc d'autre part il faut garantir une
neutralité technologique entre tous les
modes de stockage genre l'hydrogène bas
carbone issue de énergie nucléaire et
encore trop peu pris en compte par le
paquet ajustement 55 par rapport à
l'hydrogène renouvelable alors qu'il est
au fondement de la stratégie française
pour une hydrogène décarbonée de deux
doigts pas ne doit-on pas corriger le
tir d'autre part il faut consolider les
projets importants comme commun du pied
en effet il manque 1,6 milliards en
France pour le financement du piec
d'hydrogène ne peut donc pas faire
davantage et j'ai terminé mon propos
mais c'est le président le premier
enseignement que vous venez nous
apporter qui confirme ce que nous avons
pu déjà débattre dans nos différentes
commissions c'est que le dossier
énergétique va être déterminant sur le
positionnement des activités
industrielles économiques sur nos
territoires et qu'on est dans des
situations effectivement de grandes
fragilités en et dans une fragilité
qu'on n'avait pas l'habitude de
connaître notamment en France sur la
partie énergétique qui est un élément
absolument nouveau où personne n'a été
préparé
merci merci beaucoup Daniel je poursuis
juste de question supplémentaires
faites deux interventions
supplémentaires pierre ouzulias
merci Monsieur les présidents merci à
nos notre intervenante et à nos
intervenants je dois vous avouer que en
tant que sénateur de la commission de la
culture j'ai particulièrement
apprécié votre propos qui me donne
l'illusion en sortant de cette salle
d'avoir compris quelque chose ce qui est
déjà très très précieux
j'ai surtout pardon
j'ai surtout apprécié votre votre mise
en perspective sur le long terme je
crois qu'elle est fondamentale moi je
retiens quelques idées et vous me direz
si si je me trompe c'est que jusqu'à
présent le marché européen finalement il
a il a fonctionné comme quelque chose
qui permettait de répartir des des
de l'énergie produite en trop
aujourd'hui on change complètement de de
perspective et l'Europe et la France
singulièrement doit faire face à deux
enjeux qui sont extrêmement importants
qui sont historiques c'est premièrement
développer une production énergétique
qui permet d'assurer nos souverainetés
et donc de retenir et là je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec ce qu'a dit notre
collègue grammier de retenir des en des
entreprises qui seraient aujourd'hui
susceptibles de partir à l'étranger
parce que l'énergie est moins forte et
on voit très bien que c'est le jeu des
États-Unis de façon extrêmement claire
et ensuite de décarboner ces industries
ce qui nous redonnerait à nous des
marges de compétitivité et ensuite
assurer la transition énergétique et
ensuite il vous l'avez dit très
justement mais
la commission des affaires culturelles
le voit sur tous les dossiers il faut
réintroduire dans dans le fonctionnement
de tout ça des grands principes
géostratégiques puisque ce qui a été mis
à mal dans la stabilité relative c'est
la déflagration de la guerre menée par
la Russie contre le crâne qui nous
oblige aujourd'hui à abandonner le monde
des illusions d'une Europe en paix
éternellement et qui nous oblige à
protéger nos industries pour des raisons
géo géostratégique ce qui fait que et
dans vos propos c'était clair reviennent
des idées très fortes liées à la
planification et c'est quand même le
paradoxe incroyable c'est que c'est
c'est que c'est la guerre menée par la
Russie qui nous oblige à revenir au
Gosplan enfin je le dis de façon un peu
un peu un peu en plaisantant mais mais
on comprend bien dans votre esprit que
il y a eu aujourd'hui une impérioso
planifier et de planifier dans le temps
long alors ma question c'est est-ce que
les États nationaux peuvent le faire
seuls est-ce que la France peut le faire
seul ou au contraire est-ce que la seule
échelle pour mener à bien ses politiques
c'est l'échelle européenne merci
merci Pierre Patrick Chauvet
bien Messieurs les Présidents madame
messieurs les différents intervenants
d'abord merci de vos interventions et de
votre présence ici une question très
courte le Senna examine actuellement le
projet de loi d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables donc je suis le
rapporteur pour notre commission dans ce
cadre notre commission à veiller à
consolider les modes de financement
privé des énergies décarbonées nous
avons ainsi institué des contrats de
long terme pour l'énergie nucléaire et
des contrats d'achat direct pour
l'électricité renouvelable ces nouveaux
modes de financement privé ne
doivent-ils pas être davantage
encouragés dans le cadre de la réforme
du marché européen de l'électricité ils
ne sont
pas même mentionnés dans leur règlement
du 6 octobre 2022
non plus dans le plan ripower ou le
paquet ajustement 55 je vous remercie
merci merci Patrick et on termine avec
Serge Mériot qui saute
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
intervenants
enfin moi j'ai appris aussi beaucoup de
choses il y a des choses que j'ai pas
très compris dans les mécanismes du
marché mais ce que j'ai remarqué c'est
que le mot le plus utilisé ce matin
quand on parle d'énergie c'est le mot
marcher aujourd'hui si vous voulez
l'électricité
est un bien qui est soumis aux appétits
du marché alors et je pense que là on a
une conception totalement
divergente
des prix de l'énergie c'est un bien donc
qui est soumis aux lois du marché alors
que moi je considère que c'est un bien
commun c'est un bien qui ne doit pas
être donc soumis à ces fameuses appétits
du marché parce que aujourd'hui ce qu'on
constate c'est que bien sûr il y a une
crise une rupture
non seulement parce que l'énergie est
chère mais parce que leur marché de
production de produits industriels est
en train de s'effondrer compte tenu des
prix auxquels ils devaient vendre et
puis un point de détail sur sur le
stockage de notamment de l'électricité
puisque bon le stockage du gaz c'est que
ça pose pas de problème particulier mais
sur l'hydroélectricité on avait un
certain EDF avait un certain nombre de
projets de
après avoir
turbiné produit de l'électricité avec de
l'eau de remonter aux périodes où la
demande en électricité était faible de
remonter l'eau vers des des lacs
resitués en dessus des barrages pour
travailler plusieurs fois ce taux là et
ce projet là
on en a un très gros sur la vallée de la
Dordogne qui est toujours
qui pour lequel techniquement il
fonctionne mais pour lequel on n'avance
pas donc je pense qu'il y a des idées à
creuser au niveau du stockage de
l'électricité et notamment sur
l'hydraulique voilà merci
bien on va vous demander de répondre
finalement on pourrait enchaîner sur une
nouvelle table ronde qui serait plus de
façon plus simpliste le marché a-t-il
protégé ou aggraver la situation
finalement c'est un peu c'est un peu ça
moi j'aurais tendance à dire qu'on
écoutant nos interlocuteurs on a
peut-être évité quelque chose de pire
voilà je c'est plutôt ce que j'ai ce que
j'ai entendu mais il y a pas mal de
choses sur lesquelles on est raccord
c'est effectivement sur la façon de
stocker qui est peut-être un sujet aussi
et puis et puis la production
les façons de produire de produire
l'énergie et puis il y a aussi
l'intégration et je ne prends la défense
de personnes mais de ce qu'on a connu là
qui n'était pas probablement prévu ni
intégrer dans les modèles de marché tel
qu'ils ont été qu'ils ont été établis et
surtout aussi dans nos modes de
consommation
peut-être qu'aussi l'industrie si elle
doit réduire aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
parce qu'elle était au lit elle est
allée aussi un peu loin donc il y a je
pense qu'il y a quelque chose de plus de
plus aggloméré à intégrer avant de se
prononcer mais je crois que ce serait ce
serait intéressant d'aller jusque là
donc voilà je sais pas vous organiser
moi j'ai pas d'organisation particulière
ni franc non plus sur la une façon dont
vous voulez répondre mais répondez là où
vous sentez le plus à l'aise
allez on refait un tour dans dans le
même ordre aller dans le même ordre
je veux bien me lancer
je suis universitaire donc je ne rende
compte qu'à moi-même
je pense que pour l'instant nous n'avons
pas connu le pire et que le pire est
toujours possible et que le pire serait
la rupture de l'approvisionnement de
l'électricité donc des coupures
tournantes etc et des ruptures
d'approvisionnement en gaz dont nous ne
sommes pas sortis puisque si j'exagère
nous dépendons du temps du du je sais
plus comment dire français pardonnez-moi
si on dit pas climat température
dépendons de la température
et on n'a pas de vision sur les
températures de l'année prochaine de
rien
ensuite
grosse déception de ma part comme
universitaire les Américains nous
laissent tomber peut-être que c'est
normal peut-être peut-être qu'on rêve
sur les Américains mais il nous laisse
tomber et il nous laisse tomber au
moment le pire pour nous puisque comme
plusieurs d'entre vous l'ont dit on a
vraiment une rupture géopolitique on
était sincèrement persuadés Didier
dirait certainement pas le contraire
qu'on avait trouvé quand même un deal
avec les risques bon ils sont
insupportables
tous les tous les quatre ans ils font la
guerre à quelqu'un mais que néanmoins
ils font des petites guerres et puis
pour ça passera mais non on est désolé
ça passe pas ils sont engagés dans des
ruptures on peut dire mondial et ça
passe pas pour nous
ça passe pas pour nous et on sait pas
trop comme comment sortir et je suis
d'accord que on peut avoir très
facilement une nouvelle vague de
désindustrialisation c'est évident dans
les grands industries pour tetrices
c'est évident dans les grands
consommateurs d'énergie j'ai été choquée
mais c'est normal que la moitié de la
citologie s'arrête à force que que
la moitié l'aluminium s'arrête que
l'industrie papetière française produit
ou trois quarts de sa capacité mais
parce qu'ils sont entièrement à Rennes
sans la reine il produirait à zéro et
ceci est devant nous et comme je l'ai
dit en conclusion de mes 6 slides je ne
sais pas comment faire
et
le fait que nous protégions davantage
les consommateurs je le comprends pour
des raisons sociales je suis aussi moi
d'origine de famille très pauvre je
comprends très bien le sens social et
c'est très important qu'on n'est pas de
fraction entière de notre pays qui se
sentent abandonné
mais
et notre industrie c'est très bien que
les femmes les consommateurs mais le
sujet industriel monte en importance et
je ne connais pas la solution je suis
très franc avec vous et je suis
également déçu comme vous tous que notre
nucléaire ait eu cette défaillance
évidemment il en sortira mais on ne sait
pas quand et de toute façon dans
l'avenir proche avant 2035 on n'a pas de
nouveau nucléaire donc dans l'avenir
proche c'est on peut préparer le
nucléaire pour 2035 mais dans les 13 ans
à venir notre avenir n'est pas dans le
renouveau du clair c'est simplement les
centrales existantes vont fonctionner
donc je suis d'accord qu'il y a des très
très gros sujets sur la table et je n'en
connais pas la solution et je suis déçu
que pour l'instant les Américains nous
laisse tomber
merci beaucoup monsieur Lachamp monsieur
Ménard s'il vous plaît
je suis pas exactement dans la même
situation que Monsieur glachon pour ma
parole
je voudrais revenir sur un certain
nombre de points qui ont été évoqués par
les par les uns et les autres
premier point moi je suis très sensible
à ça
on a monté les institutions que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui en période
d'abondance
certains pensaient même
que les moyens de production disponibles
d'énergie électrique était trop
importante
donc là on découvre d'un seul coup
bah non il y a plus abondance
et qu'on manque de moyens de production
électrique il faut bien voir que c'est
pour moi c'est vraiment ça
la leçon de la crise
on a bâti des institutions qui étaient
là pour gérer ce qui était interprété
comme une suracumulation de capital le
parc nucléaire français était trop
important
les centrales à gaz ont été mis sous
capuchon au début des années 2010 etc
etc on est plus du tout dans cette
situation là
alors le fait que c'est qui ait eu en
arrière-plan cette situation d'abondance
explique probablement les faiblesses les
plus criants
du système de marché actuel on n'a pas
fait très attention à envoyer des bons
signaux de long terme pour les
investisseurs puisque de toute façon on
estimait qu'on était en surcapacité
on est plus du tout là dessus
et d'une certaine façon le travail qu'on
doit faire maintenant
il a pas été fait
il faut combattre un système qui envoie
les bons signaux
pour des investisseurs parce qu'on a
besoin de capacité de production
électrique supplémentaire
on en a besoin pour plusieurs raisons la
raison essentielle c'est que
tous les pays d'Europe se sont engagés
dans une réduction de leurs émissions
qui passent inévitablement par une
électrification
d'un certain nombre d'usages donc on a
besoin de plus d'électricité
donc je pense que le sujet
de la réforme du marché de l'électricité
c'est de passer de la gestion de
surcapacité
à la gestion d'investissement de vous
c'est ça le sujet
et ça
ça implique un certain nombre de
changements dans la façon dont on prend
les choses
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de la
défiance qui avait la Commission
européenne
pour les contrats de long terme à un
moment donné
bien je considère que le changement
profond qu'on vient de subir
est une excellente raison de jeter à la
rivière cette défiance pour les
contrastes de long terme
ça c'est un premier point deuxième point
un tout petit peu plus précis
sur les modalités de financement du
nouveau nucléaire j'ai entendu la
question
effectivement on a un panel de solutions
aujourd'hui qui seront utilisées par des
par différents États membres
pour rebondir sur la présentation de
Monsieur Blachon le modèle qui a été
développé au Royaume-Uni aujourd'hui
attire vraiment l'attention
donc en particulier sur
sizewell C
on est sur un système de rémunération
qui prévoit
que pendant la phase de construction on
apporte une rémunération aux porteur du
projet qui lui permet
d'aller financer son projet
donc je vais pas rentrer dans la
technique mais
cet aspect là de ce qui a été mis enfin
encore complètement mis en place qui est
en discussion nous paraît un modèle
extrêmement intéressant
voilà
monsieur perso
oui je vais répondre en effet aux
quelques questions qui ont été posées
alors je partage la vie qui a été
exprimée à l'instant sur le nucléaire je
pense en effet que la taxonomie cet acte
délégué c'est un compromis politique qui
est pas du tout favorable à la France
puisque pour je dirais y inclure
nucléaire qui a failli ne pas y être il
a fallu faire des concessions aux
Allemands et les dates limites qui ont
été imposées 2040 et 2045 sont en effet
préjudiciables à la relance du nucléaire
en Europe sur le financement de
nucléaire je pense que aujourd'hui il
faut en effet s'orienter vers les trois
solutions qui à l'échelle mondiale
semble retenir l'attention le système in
clim point du contrat pour différence
qui a beaucoup de vertus le système de
la base d'actifs réguliers de sizewell
qui a d'autres vertus notamment de
permettre une rémunération au fil de
l'eau pour au fil de la construction
pour l'opérateur et le système des
pipiers
les Japonais semblent intéressés par un
projet de centrale nucléaire qui serait
financé par des pipiers c'est-à-dire au
fond les appels des appels au
financement les financeurs profitant à
ce moment-là de droite tirage sur la
production nucléaire je rappelle que
celle-ci s'aiment qui avait été mis en
place ça a fait sennheim parce que vous
aviez une compagnie allemande une
compagnie suisse qui avait des droits de
tirage et en participer au financement
alors tout ça c'est un problème de
partage de risque les trois systèmes
contrats pour différences la base actifs
régulée les pipiers le partage de risque
est pas le même entre l'opérateur l'état
donc le contribuable et le consommateur
chacun a ses vertus chaque système a ses
vertus et ses inconvénients je veux pas
trop trop m'étendre mais je crois que
c'est ça qu'il faut regarder concernant
l'hydraulique je voudrais rappeler que
au moment de la commission Champsaur il
était prévu de parler non pas de la
reine au départ mais de la Rb l'accès
régulier à la base c'est à dire qu'il
était prévu
qu'on fait pas seulement de
l'électricité il y a d'autres usages et
je crois que c'est un atout pour la
France je rappelle qu'en 1960 la moitié
de la production d'électricité française
était hydraulique même aujourd'hui ça
n'est que 12% parce qu'entre temps
évidemment la consommation a fortement
grimpé mais c'est un atout qu'il faut
faudrait pas ouvrir à la concurrence je
pense que ça c'est une pépite nationale
qu'il faut absolument absolument garder
alors concernant le stockage de
l'électricité je crois en effet bon on
veut on veut absolument mettre des
couleurs sur l'hydrogène alors il y a
toute la panoplie on a quasiment
l'arc-en-ciel alors mais l'hydrogène
jaune pour le nucléaire en montant qu'il
est pas tout à fait vert bon pourquoi
pas j'observe quand même que les
écologistes Allemands sont prêts à
prendre de l'hydrogène fait avec le
nucléaire ce qui est plutôt un bon
signal envoyé à la communauté
internationale européenne en particulier
je pense en effet qu'il y a beaucoup pas
faire du côté d'hydrogène comme solution
de stockage alors l'hydrogène on peut
soit l'utiliser comme combustible c'est
à dire faire simplement l'électrolyse de
l'eau soit ensuite repasser à la
production d'électricité il est vrai que
aujourd'hui avec les technologies
disponibles et les coûts actuels le
rendement global du ce qu'on appelle le
power to gaz tout power il est de
l'ordre de 30 % donc c'est relativement
faible pas peut-être un petit peu plus
mais enfin il est de l'ordre il est pas
très élevé alors il y a des espoirs sur
des systèmes beaucoup plus performants
pour pour demain je crois qu'il faut
regarder là ce qui peut être ce qui peut
être fait
concernant la planification et le marché
la question pour moi n'est pas vraiment
est-ce que c'est le plan ou l'état le
plan ou le marché
je restais les deux le problème c'est la
frontière entre les deux
on peut avoir un service public qui est
rendu avec les contraintes de marché et
d'ailleurs le rapport c'est le rapport
si mon aura de 1967 disait il faut
pratiquer une tarification sur la base
la vérité des prix pour les services
publics en particulier pour
l'électricité il faut la généraliser à
l'ensemble des services publics ça se
défend tout à fait la consommation
d'électricité c'est une consommation qui
identifiable elle est virée on sait qui
consomme et donc c'est pas c'est pas
comme les biens collectifs qu'on appelle
les biens collectifs purs qui
correspondent aux fonctions régaliennes
de l'État là c'est tout à fait légitime
que le consommateur paye alors il faut
aider ceux qui sont en situation de
précarité énergétique mais là le marché
je crois un rôle le marché est incitatif
le rôle du marché c'est de supprimer des
rentes tendus et c'est aussi d'inciter à
l'innovation je crois que c'est ce sont
les deux grands mérides du marché la
concurrence à ces mérite là il faut
surtout en profiter alors c'est vrai que
un état performant peut sur le long
terme faire les bons choix s'il est pas
performant il peut aussi faire sur les
long terme de mauvais choix l'avantage
du marché c'est que la sanction tombe à
un moment ou un autre donc je crois que
de ce point de vue c'est c'est une bonne
chose merci
merci je voudrais répondre peut-être
juste sur deux points d'une part
sur ce qu'a dit Monsieur Grémillet je
voudrais rappeler que dans les énergies
nouvelles et renouvelables il y en a une
qui est parfaitement stockable ça
s'appelle le biométhane ou le biogaz et
que le potentiel est loin d'être
négligeable on estime qu'en France c'est
40 terawattheure à 2030 c'est
de l'ordre 250 térawatters à
2050 en Europe les chiffres sont
équivalents
York and by yoga association nous
annonce 41 milliards de mètres cubes
c'est-à-dire en gros 450 térawattheure
pour
2000 2030 et 151 milliards de mètres
cubes c'est-à-dire 1700 terawattheure
pour
2050 donc je pense que une des priorités
de la crise actuelle ça doit être
d'accélérer le développement de la
production de biométhane en créant des
conditions favorables alors qui sont en
partie dans les dans la loi
d'accélération des ENR en partie aussi
en ajustant les tarifs parce que
l'inflation touche aussi la construction
des installations de biomethane pour
permettre que la dynamique qui a été
créée ce prolonge deuxièmement
s'agissant des contrats long terme du
souci de long terme dans
l'approvisionnement de gaz puisqu'il a
un impact sur le marché électricité je
voudrais rappeler qu'une des difficultés
que nous identifions c'est qu'en fait
dans la création du marché européen plus
personne n'était en charge de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement côté gaz
alors il se trouve qu'en France
par tradition
nous avons
les principes de sécurité
d'approvisionnement donc de la
diversification des sources ont été
préservés
en partie d'ailleurs parce que les
acteurs étaient plus concentrés
même si EDF si est juin en gros il y
avait historiquement engie et total et
c'était ils avaient tous les deux dans
leur Gênes ces soucis de diversification
en Allemagne du fait de la
diversification de la diversité des
opérateurs et du fait qu'il n'y avait
pas de responsabilité ce souci de
diversification c'est perdu et donc est
à l'origine de la crise mais
aujourd'hui on pourrait faire à nouveau
des contrats long terme avec d'autres
sources que que la Russie on pense en
particulier aux États-Unis au Qatar plus
marginalement sur du gaz de gazoduc avec
le turcménistan ou quelques les autres
pays éventuellement même l'Algérie
l'est méditerranéen le Mozambique etc ce
qui manque aujourd'hui c'est la capacité
pour des opérateurs de faire des
contrats long terme qui soit indexées
sur autre chose que le prix court terme
du marché du gaz européen si vous faites
des contrats long terme indexées sur le
TTF pour faire court
title transfer facility qui est le prix
du gaz sur le marché spot
au Pays-Bas
vous n'avez pas couvert votre problème
d'exposition au risque si en revanche
vous diversifiez en prenant du gaz
américain indexé sur Henry hub qui est
le prix directeur américain du gaz
qatari indexé sur le prix du pétrole
puisque c'est ainsi que les catharis
vendent aux asiatiques et une partie une
partie de TTF une partie éventuellement
sur d'autres indices vous avez à
introduit un nouveau principe de
diversification qui est la
diversification des Indes ce qui veut
dire que vous lâcherez jamais au moins
cher mais vous n'achèterez jamais non
plus au plus cher des prix marginaux et
ça aujourd'hui le cadre n'est pas fait
pour que ça se fasse pourquoi est-ce
qu'on voit malgré la guerre en Ukraine
que très peu de nouveaux contrats long
terme sont signés par des entreprises
européennes
parce que les Américains voudraient
signer sur une base aérienne parce que
les catharis voudraient signer sur une
base Brent et que nous Européens acteurs
du gaz européen pour ne pas être à
risque nous avons intérêt à refléter
dans nos contrats d'approvisionnement le
prix du coup du marché de gros
européens c'est-à-dire qu'à la fin on
fait tout porter sur le même indice TTF
qui présente un risque élevé de
volatilité voilà ce que je voulais dire
évidemment ça ça a un impact à long
terme sur le prix de l'électricité mais
si
on crée les conditions pour que un mix
de prix diversifié du gaz servent au
moins à fournir l'électricité marginale
produite à partir du gaz en Europe on
aurait des solutions qui
préserveraient d'un certain nombre de
pics de prix et d'un certain nombre
d'effets négatifs de la volatilité merci
de votre attention
oui on donne la parole à nos invités en
visio mais peut-être
ça ne plus connecté
non je crois que ils sont déconnectés
si vous voulez répondre un peu aux
questions telles que elles ont été
posées merci
pour moi le mot clé pour cette
discussion et long terme
la transition énergétique est un
processus long terme et comme Monsieur
Menard a dit les investisseurs ont
besoin des signaux long terme aussi les
consommateurs en fait ont besoin des
signaux long terme si on avait une
meilleure mixtée des signaux court terme
et des signaux long terme dans le prix
pour les consommateurs on avait une
situation très différente aujourd'hui
c'est alors cette réforme c'est cet
sujet que c'est très fort doit apprécier
et le troisième point pour moi c'est
c'est le système pour
identifier et coordiner les besoins des
du système parce que la transition
énergétique est aussi un processus de
changement du système d'énergétique et
on va voir une une un changement profond
de le système une décentralisation
et aussi les besoins du système vont
changer
on doit bien monitorer bien
comprendre
ces changements et on doit faire des
mesures des investissements à des cas
pour atrécier ces changements et ça ce
sont les
éléments clés pour cette réforme merci
beaucoup
peut-être
les déconnecter
vous y rajouter quelque chose peut-être
ah non elle est là elle est là je vous
donne la parole après
merci
[Musique]
à travers trois points courtes donc
premièrement la question de protection
des consommateurs il faut il faut que
nous
analysons beaucoup plus en détail et en
profondeur comment nous pouvons protéger
les consommateurs le ménage et les
compagnies à tous les deux et surtout
aussi les consommateurs vulnérables quel
est le rôle de secteur public ici et
quels sont les responsabilités propres à
chacun de nous et à chaque compagnie
pour se protéger donc il faut trouver la
bonne équilibre
deuxièmement je pense qu'il faut
souligner
l'efficacité de échanges au niveau
européen donc la efficacité de marché
pour assurer que les modes de production
les moins coûteux sont toujours à
consommer avant que les productions plus
coûteuses entre dans le mix
et nous voyons ça clairement en France
aujourd'hui
sans les importations de tous vos
voisins je pense que la situation aussi
bien le prix que la disponibilité de
l'électricité serait beaucoup plus
difficile à sans le marché européen
qu'il est aujourd'hui donc préserver
l'efficacité des échanges et les marchés
européens et le dernier point
concerne les investissements dans la
capacité à que dont nous avons besoin
dans l'avenir donc ici je pense qu'il
faut prendre le temps et bien réfléchir
donc quel est le rôle de planification
personnellement je pense qu'il faut plus
de planification parce que les États
membres sont très différents il y a des
États membres qui passent leur mix sur
le nucléaire comme la France il y a des
États membres qui ont encore beaucoup de
charbon dans leur mixte de production et
qui doivent accélérer la transition donc
comment toutes ces différences à
différentes mixes au niveau européen à
son planifiées de telle façon que nous
avons toujours de électricité et à
moindre coût donc je pense que cette
question revient à tout ce qui a été
discuté aujourd'hui les
capacités mécanismes à les aux
investissements
comment assurer qu'il y a
de flexibilité de stockage en plus de
capacité de production de base et cette
modèle de investissement
nécessite à mon avis une réflexion
peut-être plus long terme que le temps
que nous avons pour faire la proposition
avant 10 mars merci beaucoup
oui
un petit point je voulais souligner que
eurogaz soutient fortement la
développement de l'hydrogène de toutes
ces formes bas carbone comme étant une
partie de la solution de
du problème énergétique avec évidemment
une très forte corrélation pour le coup
entre le marché du gaz hydrogène et de
et de l'électricité et j'ai un léger des
accords avec Monsieur Percebois en
utilisant des technologies d'électrolyse
du type de sel développé par le CEA avec
genevia et en utilisant des piles à
combustibles par exemple pour sur un
couplet sur un réseau de chaleur pour
que la chaleur soit également réutilisée
vous arrivez à des rendements de cycles
de l'ordre de 80%. c'est-à-dire vous
êtes à pratiquement 99% en rapport PCI
sur NRJ sur l'électrolyse et vous êtes à
56 % de production de rendement
production électrique sur votre pile à
combustible mais si vous mettez la plus
en plus vous êtes à 80%. donc
l'hydrogène pour faire de la pointe
électrique c'est loin d'être absurde à
partir du moment où on intègre les
nouvelles technologies et où on intègre
le fait qu'il y a des réseaux suffisants
pour connecter des cavités salines qui
permettent le stockage pas cher de
l'hydrogène avec les lieux de production
d'électricité par pile à combustible
je crois qu'on a fait le tour s'il y a
pas de demande de parole complémentaires
merci beaucoup messieurs et Madame
pour pour votre apport vos contributions
votre apport qui nous sera peut-être
très utile dans les dans les travaux que
nous allons poursuivre évidemment donc
je te laisse
beaucoup contraint on pourrait rester là
quasiment toute la journée mais je l'ai
dit effectivement sur sur la question de
de le marché prothèse protège-t-il ou ne
protège-t-il pas je pense que on
pourrait avoir une réflexion beaucoup
plus profonde sur sur la question merci
en tout cas je retiens alors je n'envoie
qu'un parce que tous sont partis il y a
séance les membres de la commission des
affaires européennes car la commission
n'est pas terminée j'ai encore une
communication à faire mais il